frank dir liegt die strafakte des
tatverdächtigen vor
was hast du also jetzt über ihn erfahren
können eine akte dieser person wohnt die
behörden gegenüber gesagt haben es
handelt sich da um diesen verdächtigen
wo man glaubt dass er auch des mordes an
der die verdächtige ist die leiche fehlt
ja bis heute aber sie gehen davon aus
dass das mädchen von ihm vermutlich
missbraucht und dann getötet wurde ist
es sehr sehr auffällig das ist erst mal
quer durchs strafgesetzbuch geht also
erscheint im regal berufskriminelle zu
sein schwerpunkte liegen allerdings
immer bei sexualstraftaten bei
drogenhandel auch bei herstellung von
drogen da geht es auch einmal quer durch
von synthetischen drogen über cannabis
und andere dinge und einbruchsdiebstahl
erscheint also richtig seinen
lebensunterhalt auf der einen seite mit
bestritten zu haben und auf der anderen
seite immer wieder auch dieses
sexualstraftaten deswegen er momentan
auch in der jva sitzen und diese tat ihm
da vorgeworfen wird ist aus dem jahre
2005 auch an der algarve der handelt
sich aber um eine ältere dame was einige
erstmal stützen ist auf der einen seite
immer wieder der vorwurf und auch die
verurteilung sexueller missbrauch von
kindern verbreitung
kinderpornografischer schriften dann auf
der anderen seite eine ältere frau und
ein ermittler sagte uns das sei bei
profilern bekannt dass solche täter in
der regel sich immer opfer suchen wir
nicht gegenwehr leisten und das ist bei
kindern und älteren menschen natürlich
der fall
und ihm ist trotzdem nur um seine
dominanz geht und um dieses missbrauchs
geschehen und dass er die dominanz über
über personen ausüben kann und was auch
noch auffällt an der akt ist dass die
taten in deutschland 95 enden und 2007
wieder beginnen das ist ja genau die
zeit in der er sich an der algarve
aufgehalten haben soll und wo die
polizei davon ausgeht dass in diesem
zeitraum auch die tat an mir fällt
vielen dank frank schneider für diese
einblicke